i don't think it's gonna be very long
the numbers were already on their way up
before
freedom day uh became a thing and
certainly the nhs
is already under pressure from
non-coveted work we've got record
attendances with quite a lot of a e
departments
we've got elected surgery being
cancelled in a lot of places so what we
really don't need at the moment is a lot
of people turning up at hospital with
covid as well
fortunately as you just heard the
numbers of people being hospitalized
with kovids
haven't risen quite so sharply but if
the numbers in the community keep going
up inevitably the numbers coming into
hospital will come up as well
and that's going to affect elective care
planned care as well
and how do you feel about the nhs app
and people deleting it
it's very unfortunate i think if you
blame the app for it it overlooks the
point which is that the app is
reflecting the huge rate of transmission
in the community the reason
there's a pandemic is because there's a
pandemic you know people are being
infected and testing positive in huge
numbers and blaming the app for that
uh is like blaming a fire alarm for
going off when there's a fire
um but not as many people are dying
of course as as we will know so that
chain thankfully has
been broken um and all the people that
are many of the people that are
isolating don't necessarily have kovid
but nevertheless they can't
work for that week and we've seen the
supermarket shelves empty as a result
sure and it's certainly having an impact
on the economy i completely see that and
uh the the problem is that we've still
got some proportion of people who've
been vaccinated are still getting ill
if you've got millions of people all get
catching the disease
and only a tiny proportion of our ending
up in hospital that's still a large
number a small proportion
of a large number is still a big number
and hospitals as i say don't have a lot
of spare capacity at the moment we're
really stretched with everything else
quite aside from covid certainly there
needs to be some consideration of
whether people have been vaccinated
maybe could have a different regime uh
maybe
as has suggested they're you know being
tested to release
or something like that but at the moment
the numbers being pinged
reflect the numbers being infected
because we've released all the
restrictions
okay um doctor you came on to talk about
the um three percent
pay rise offer for nhs workers i mean it
it's what has been suggested recommended
by an independent
pay body to the government so there
can't really be any real argument with
that can they
the pay review body that's made that
recommendation has
part of its purpose is to make sure that
doctors
want to stay in the nhs to make sure
that there's recruitment going on and
honestly over the last 10 years our pay
has fallen in value by about a third
because we've had year after year after
year of getting below inflation pay
rises
this doesn't really go very far towards
addressing that i mean inflation this
year is
projected to be more than three percent
andy haldane at the bank of england is
talking about four percent
um so this is probably going to turn out
to be yet another below inflation pay
rise
at a time when doctors are leaving the
nhs they're exhausted by the last
year and a half and we really really
need people to stay this isn't going to
do that
okay um do you think that we sh that
your
your organization yours and nurses other
healthcare workers would potentially
consider industrial action
we're not at that stage yet what we're
going to be doing uh we're going to be
sending out a survey to our members
today and over the next week or so to
check and make sure that they are as
angry and disappointed about this
pay offer as as we are at the bma and if
so what they're prepared to do about it
and
industrial action will be on that list
of things they might want to consider
and we'll see what people are prepared
to do to defend their pay
okay um thank you on behalf of all of my
viewers for the amazing work that you do
thank you very much let's hope the
government recognizes it too okay thank
you